[Music]
the cdc
is warning about a distressing trend in
the pandemic
coronavirus cases are increasing in
nearly 75 percent of the country
over the past week the u.s averaged
almost 60 000
new cases a day the country is also
seeing an average of more than
700 deaths a day with a total now above
222 thousand more than 1100 people died
just yesterday
health and human services secretary alex
azar has called the trends concerning
he joins us now good morning mr
secretary thanks for being with us
uh you said we're only weeks away
from a safe and effective vaccine when
do you believe it would be widely
available to the general population
well anthony just to clarify i think
weeks to months we can't predict exactly
when we'll get data
so there are independent data and safety
monitoring board that will have to
review the data a drug company will have
to determine data meets their standards
and none of this happens of course until
we get enough events in those clinical
trials and we have no control over that
what we've said is
that we believe because thanks to
president trump we're manufacturing
all six vaccines at commercial scale
right now
we believe by the end of this year we
would have enough fda authorized vaccine
to vaccinate our most vulnerable people
by the end of january enough vaccine for
all of our seniors as well as our
health care workers and first responders
and by the end of march to early april
enough for all americans
healthbert health experts mr secretary
although say a vaccine won't immediately
get us back to normal
that we could need to be taking
precautions like wearing a mask
well into next year so how long do you
think we're going to be living
like this well anthony i don't want to
speculate like that let's get the
vaccines up and running let's get that
vaccination program going let's see the
effect that they
have in terms of increasing uh what we
would call
herd immunity from vaccination and then
let's also see
we hope we'll be having these monoclonal
antibody therapies
fairly soon we have two emergency use
authorization submissions into fda
as the next generation treatments to
help reduce severity and impact of this
disease but
let's take it one day at a time rather
than trying to forecast what things are
going to look like many months from now
politico is reporting uh this morning mr
secretary that you are
openly plotting the ouster of fda chief
stephen hahn
due to deep frustration with han over
his insistence that a covid 19 vaccine
meets stricter than normal safety
standards do you have a problem
with the fda chief absolutely untrue in
fact commissioner hahn and i speak
almost every day
we have a very close productive
relationship and we're working together
as
i have made very clear and the
commissioners made clear
the fda will make the decision whether
to approve therapeutics or vaccines
according to their science
data regulatory and legal standards
those calls we made ultimately by the
top
career officials at the fda and i 100
support that approach so you're
confident he can lead the vaccine effort
absolutely okay i wanted to ask you
lawyers appointed by a judge to find
parents who were separated from their
children at the border
say they can't locate or reach the
families of 545
of those children those kids are under
hhs care which obviously you're in
charge of
what is your plan for those children so
anthony let's actually be clear you made
a very substantial misstatement there
no child within our care is from any of
the separation policies
that work by the aclu with the court was
under court order to look back to some
activity that occurred back in 2017
none of the children associated with
that are in our care they're
all out in foster care or more
importantly with
family members here in the united states
we are reviewing that filing and
we'll certainly work with the court on
any proceedings related to that
all right the cdc meanwhile has updated
its guidance on how
the coronavirus can spread from person
to person
can you explain this new guidance and
how perhaps we need to better protect
ourselves
yeah anthony let me make three key
points first we're learning every day
about this virus
second the cdc is going to update their
guidance and educate the american
people as we learn this is really new
information that we've learned from some
recent studies
and third here's what the guidance says
which is that we
in the past had said that to be a close
contact of somebody who might be
infectious you needed to have 15 minutes
of continuous
unbroken contact with them within six
feet
now the caution is that you might need
to actually if you have
iterative interactions within that six
feet even if it's not 15 minutes
unbroken
that you might also be a close contact
what this means is
it's a real call to action to reiterate
wash your hands
watch your distance and when you cannot
watch your distance
wear your face coverings to protect
yourself and
others and stay out of settings where
you can't do those things so i think
it's a
just a real up-to-date reminder of the
absolute importance of practicing those
three w's
all right secretary azar thank you so
much for being with us this morning